here's how you can find me in cyberpunk
2077 a lot of people have been asking
lately since I guess a lot of people are
playing cyberpunk 2077 again and yes I
am a character specific to The Nomad
path I sent them some pictures of my
face which they use to create the model
it's obviously not exactly me her name
is Lana Prince and did the voice
recording for it which I will admit I
really do not like my performance in
this but I'm honored to be a part of it
anyway so if you want to find me you do
have to play as a nomad specifically and
it's a quest called These boots are made
for walking which will unlock in Act 2
you should have entally just get a ping
that somebody has found your old car and
when you start to do that Quest it will
send you to a location where you will
find me with your car what happens in
the uing conversation is up to you if
you do find me please take a picture
with me and your V and tag me I always
love seeing them it's so much fun